- Hello everyone and
welcome to this bonus video
here on Firm Learning.
And the reason that I do this video
is that a couple of
days ago it was actually
my one year anniversary
of doing this channel.
I uploaded the first video on this channel
on January 17th of 2020,
and since then the growth
for sure surprised me.
So, I got over 75,000 subscribers
in the first year of doing
this channel here on YouTube.
So, over the last months I
got several people asking me,
"Okay Heinrich, how did you do it?
"How does it work?
"Do you have any insights
"on how to grow your
YouTube channel faster?"
So in this video, I will show
you the actual real back end
of my YouTube analytics of Firm Learning.
I will show you how
the growth looked like,
how it happened over time,
and I trust there are some good learnings
to be drawn from that.
And even if you don't have
your own YouTube channel
and are also not interested
in starting one anytime soon,
I do believe it is very
worthwhile to understand
this whole system better
to understand a bit better
how YouTube actually works,
how it promotes the videos,
how this growth actually happens.
So, hang in here with me,
I promise there are some good learnings
to be taken out from this.
So, welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich and on my channel
I want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
But, before we look
into the backend, guys,
I need to ask you something.
I do not understand this.
As you know, I do my very best
to answer every single
comment that you write me,
but for whatever reason,
pretty much since the very
start of this channel,
I keep getting this comment,
"Get into the choppa."
Guys, what are you even talking about?
What is this all about?
I don't get it.
Whatever guys, let's now jump
into the YouTube analytics
and let's check it out.
This is my YouTube analytics backend.
This is what I see
if I look into the
statistics of my channel.
And now I wanted to show
you the channel statistics
from the very beginning,
because even though the
first video that I published,
I believe it was on January 17th,
I already made this channel
quite some time before.
I believe apparently here
it was in May 28th of 2018.
And the reason was that at that time,
already I had the idea
that maybe at some point in the future
I wanted to do something like that,
I wanted to talk about
consulting contents like that.
And around this time I also created
this slide writing course
that some of you maybe know.
If you don't know it, check it out,
I'll link in the video description.
So, I had the idea maybe
let me make something
bigger out of it, a bigger platform,
and this was why I created
this YouTube channel initially.
In the beginning, I uploaded
one video to this channel.
It was, I believe, a
snippet from this course.
I didn't do any advertisement or whatever.
And here you can see that
pretty much just randomly
by YouTube promoting this one video,
I got 267 views and a
total of three subscribers.
So, was pretty much starting from zero
when on January 17th I
was starting the channel,
uploading the real video.
So, let's now look into the
growth really month by month,
how all of this looked like.
So, let me now select as a
starting point January of 2020,
because this is when this really started
when I just started uploading the videos.
So, this is now the month that
is selected, January, 2020.
So, what you can see here indeed
that on January 17th
I uploaded two videos,
so a little introduction,
and then a first video here.
And since then I pretty much started
doing one video every single month.
So, then only due to this one
and a half thousand views,
this is what I got.
And if you look here into the subscribers,
you see that already got
a couple of subscribers,
pretty much 224, only
after this half a month.
And the reason was my promotion strategy
in the very beginning was
that I was joining Facebook groups.
Student Facebook groups,
and there pretty much
promoting the channel.
Just leaving a little a message
talking about the channel,
and this really helped
me to get it all going,
to get it started to know
what this is all about.
So, let's now look into
February, one month further.
How did this develop here again?
Pretty much at this level.
So you see that after some time
I was at 565 subscribers,
so after one and a half month.
Again my main growth strategy was
the sort of Facebook game,
just joining Facebook groups,
mainly student groups in Facebook
and then just talking about it.
So let's continue, March.
So again, at some point I stopped
doing all of this with
the Facebook promotions
and you see that the views also plummeted.
I believe there was a
period of one or two weeks
probably this was this little spike,
where I tried out paid YouTube ads.
So I tried out to set
up a little ad campaign,
wherefore I believe it
was five Euro per day
for a couple of days.
I was just trying to promote a video,
and just check what that was doing.
But as you can see here
the results were pretty underwhelming.
So these are the views.
But if you now compare
this to the subscribers,
you see that even though
there were some views
I did not get hardly any
subscribers from that.
So then also stopped doing it
because I didn't see any
results from it whatsoever.
So this was March.
Now let's move to April.
And here in April now
you see that suddenly
these subscribers start to
increase a bit more organically.
And then end of April was apparently
also when I hit the 1000 subscribers.
If you look into the views
again and you see now
that suddenly there is a bit of an,
let's see, organic growth going on,
that the views are starting
to slightly increase here
without me really doing anything.
Let's look into May.
Again, this trend was
further increasing in May.
Right now you can see that this channel
started kind of to organically
pick up some steam,
pick up some action now, but
still slow and steady growth.
Now there was June.
Let's see how June looked
like and all the views,
the views are now organically
really increasing spiking here.
So very good development,
organic development,
but still of course on a low level.
Now next July.
And in July you see that
suddenly there was a spike here,
suddenly there was a spike in the views.
And this was indeed from this video.
This video, I applied to
McKinsey with this CV,
that really got picked
up by the algorithm.
This was the first time that
I really got some traction,
organic traction, from
the YouTube algorithm
that helped to move the whole
channel to the next level.
And this was also,
shortly after that I also hit
my 4,000 hours of watch time.
I believe you can see this here,
so now at this point I was at 5,600.
And as you know, in order to be part
of the YouTube partner program
and be able to earn
some money with YouTube,
you need 4,000 hours of watch time.
So this was pretty much this period
when I made this.
And of course, if you
look into the subscribers
this was also the met by
that one day, peak day,
190 subscribers that I got.
So pretty crazy increase
in the channel growth.
But then it got even more
crazy because then in August,
if you look here into the numbers
suddenly there was
another very big movement.
So this peak here was the
peak that we saw earlier
and it pretty much almost
connects to right from here.
And what was the reason, again?
It was this video which
performed very, very strongly,
still now the most viewed
video on my channel,
but then also the other two next videos,
especially this video
that was coming next,
also doing very well and then
sustaining this over time.
And this was then really also
met by the subscriber numbers
where I suddenly was jumping
to 32,000 subscribers.
And at the peak there was only one day
where I got 1,800 subscribers.
And I believe this is
really an important lesson
if you want to understand YouTube growth,
because YouTube growth is
always a step function,
it comes in little explosions.
So yes, there will be
some organic movement
where you slowly accrue
subscribers over time,
But then it just takes this one video,
this one or two videos
that for whatever reason
get picked up by the algorithm,
and that then catapult your
whole channel to the next level.
And then what is also
typical you can see it here,
then after some time,
this of course decreases.
After some time your video
was seen by most of the people
who wanted to see, and then YouTube stops
further promoting this.
And now this is of course
a trend that you can see to continue.
If you now look also in the September
if you go one month further,
it all slowly starts to decrease,
to go down again here
also in the subscribers.
And now if we go to October
you can really see how now
this was back down again.
So this level now here in subscribers,
but here also in views it
significantly decreased.
Though, of course, while this
level is much lower than this,
if you compare it to
these levels, initially,
of course this is a big
multiple of what was here.
Then of course this will help you to now
pretty much get your
channel to the next level.
And then it continued this way.
Now let's look into
November, what happened here.
Because what you see in
November is that, again,
here I was lucky and privileged enough
to have another video which
really performed well.
It was this how to take
notes for work video,
which was picked up by
the algorithm again.
You see here directly the views going up,
you see the subscribers
going up here again.
But again then similar to
what we've seen before,
this time now even quicker
that then this was also
decreasing again after some time.
So, but now end of December,
I was in pretty much 11 and a half months,
at 72 subscribers 0.8 and then the views,
this is also what you see here
is that it is slowing down again.
And now if you look at the very end,
pretty much onto today so
now the latest figures,
you can see that the views are now again
on this lower level where
they are stabilizing.
This is not the new level
which is slightly higher than this level.
So again, I believe the takeaway here
is that YouTube growth comes in steps.
It's a step function,
only takes one or two
videos to really catapult
your channel to the next level.
And then hopefully after you
come down from that level again
because yes, this will happen as well.
Then hopefully at the time
your baseline will increase,
you will stay at a new level
which will establish itself
as the new normal for you.
So my recommendation really is,
if you are thinking about
starting a YouTube channel
do not be discouraged
if in the first months
you don't see much traction.
So you see this was
really the first half year
where almost nothing happened.
Of course relative to these
peaks that I saw here.
I mean, at the time I was of course
super lucky and super satisfied
with the views that I got.
But now then suddenly it
just takes this first video
which apparently also sent a
good signal to the algorithm.
Then here the next video also
has catapulted it even higher.
And then now you're really
in need of these occasional videos
which will really perform well
just to move you up the curve,
to move you to the next level.
So I'm super excited to see
how this growth will continue.
Now over the new year 2021,
I for sure have lots of
great videos planned for you.
I get several messages every single day,
also on Instagram of people telling me
that they got their job at that Big 4,
at that MBB consulting firm,
and that they believe that
these videos really helped them.
So of course, this makes me super happy.
This alone is reason enough
to continue doing this.
So thank you so much for
supporting this channel,
to be here with me from the beginning.
And let's continue this journey together
here in this new year.
So I hope you found this insightful,
and as always if you have any questions
just leave me a comment
below in the comment section.
And as you know, I will do my very best
to answer every single
comment that you write.
If you took any value out of this at all
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and of course, subscribe to my channel
to stay up to date on all my content.
So if you want to see you more from me
follow me on Instagram,
my handle is firmlearning,
and I also have a mailing list,
you can sign up to that
via the video description.
So now I wanna say thank you
to all the members of Firm Learning,
you're really helping a lot.
This is really a significant contribution
to the cost of this channel.
So if you wanna become a member as well
hit the join button next
to the subscribe button
to learn what is all about.
I'm releasing new videos
every single Saturday
and sometimes little bonus
videos like this one.
So looking forward to see
all of you next Saturday,
thank you for hanging along here with me,
all the best to you.
Goodbye, Heinrich from Firm Learning here.
(intense music)
- No.
- [Anna] No.
(machine gun shooting rapidly)
(gun shooting)
- Run.
Go.
Get to the choppa.
(intense music)